[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome to geek week netflix geek week
2022 is all about getting you the latest
news trailers and all kinds of first
looks for your favorite netflix shows
films games and more i'm jay stoops and
i'm jacob scott thomas bertrand and i
mean also the all valley champ oh you
can't forget it put some respect on my
name
that's right and today is all about
series and we have a lot to cover so
much we're dropping new titles fresh
trailers and checking in with some of
our favorite stars it is going to be a
wild wild week and we are beyond stoked
for all the surprises in store there's
tons of horror which is totally my jam
and jacob is going to get through it
the nightmares are hard
i get scared like guillermo del toro's
cabinet of curiosities school tales the
series and all things mike flanagan i
mean what about the final season of lock
and key and i cannot
wait for shadow and bone either oh and
resident evil so many great shows so
little time so let's dive into our first
reveal of the day yeah we promised you
surprises and here we have a very first
look at one of the most highly
anticipated new shows coming in 2022
yeah let's see it
[Music]
that's what we get oh my goodness i want
more yeah i know that was barely
anything but it was still so much oh my
god the snaps i'm gonna be hearing that
when i wake up in the morning my god
that was our first look at wednesday the
new netflix series bringing to life the
twisted world of the adams family in a
whole new way yeah who doesn't love
wednesday she is a style icon i gotta
say yeah i mean i know i personally try
to emulate her style every single day
jenna ortega plays the title role along
with her disembodied ally thing and oh
my god this girl is the queen of horror
right yeah she's killing it in this new
show for the first time ever wednesday
is a teenager at the gothic nevermore
academy she gets pulled into a murder
mystery that has major implications for
her entire family wednesday features a
stellar creative team also led by
co-creators miles millar and al goff of
smallville and director tim
burton the man the myth the legend
himself so cool
for more of the latest news on wednesday
be sure to follow wednesday netflix on
instagram wednesday i mean what a major
moment to open geekweed with and we're
just getting started but i mean what
could possibly follow that i know it
seems impossible that we could have
something even more exciting but
guillermo del toro
wait really
yeah that's pretty sick
guillermo del toro is one of the most
prolific voices of the horror genre a
legend of the supernatural and he's
curating a brand new series for netflix
spotlighting some of the most creative
and innovative minds working in horror
today yeah his new show guillermo del
toro's cabinet of curiosities features
an all-star lineup of amazing talent
both in front of the camera and behind
the camera curious you know what to
expect uh let's
open that metaphorical cabinet and find
out
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
dang that was so eerie holy [ __ ] i am
i am gonna need a minute to recover from
that
i literally first of all we need more
horror anthology shows i that is my
personal jam but also the directors of
mandy the babadook holy cow that's
pretty nuts oh they had me at grenoble
del toro now i'm
gonna be counting the days i don't know
if i'm ready for all these nightmares
i don't know i'll send you some tips
i've been doing this for a while
um panels cosmetolos uh jennifer kent
katherine hardwick del toro has
entrusted some top shelf horror
directors with their own interpretations
of some of his personal favorite horror
stories i i don't i can't imagine
anything better than this yeah it's
insane i mean they're joined by a
talented star-studded cast to bring all
these stories to life i mean ben barnes
rupert grint sophia botella not to
mention andrew lincoln crispin glover
and essie davis all in one anthology
series i is this allowed it's literally
too good i'm gonna i'm gonna have a
panic attack
it's so cool to see del toro's creepy
beautiful brand of horror continuing to
take over netflix okay speaking of
creepy uh you wanna hear a scary story
it's like 9am
isn't it a little early i'm just trying
to push you
a little come on
let me teach you the ways of the horror
fans all right listen it's close to
midnight somewhere shout out to tokyo
it's the perfect time to talk about the
midnight club which is mike fanigan's
newest horror show oh yeah you mean mike
flanagan the creator of the haunting of
hill house and midnight mess
that my buddy
and we have an exclusive first look from
another familiar face uh roll coley oh
let's check it out
all right everyone um i'm rahul coley
and you may have seen me
in
some shows like uh uh midnight mass and
uh the haunting of blind manor but the
thing i probably get recognized for the
most
uh is probably last year's host of geet
week
but unfortunately i can't be
there with you guys this year uh because
i'm currently filming a new show with my
good pal mr mike flanagan um we are
currently in production for the fall of
the house of usher for netflix um i
can't really give you any details and
it's not ready um but i do have
something else that i could tease from
mr flanagan um so picture this okay
a group of teens gather around nightly
to share ghostly horror stories in like
a shape-shifting
mansion with a kind of
like
bloody history
right i probably didn't sell it that
well uh but
what i can do is now give you the first
look
at the midnight club from the master
horror himself mr mike flanagan
[Music]
to those before
to those after
to us now
and to those beyond
seen
or unseen
[Music]
here
but not here
seen her unseen
nearby here
[Music]
i can't tell like the kids are evil
or if the house is evil
i don't know what's going on
i mean i that looks so creepy at first
of all that cast looks amazing i
i'm very intrigued i love spooky teens
that's like a thing that's like a genre
that we absolutely need like his
teammates we need to tap more into
spooky teams
teens kind of freak me out like just
regular teens i'm
like you know youths but especially when
they start you know hosting midnight
vigils and stuff i'm like yeah dang well
it's so good to see raul again raul
hosted this show last year and you know
i'm still waiting for my street fighter
2 rematch come on dude you're lit you
literally okay yeah michael
i still think he cheated i mean i think
they had some backstage stuff going on i
i believe in you i'm rooting for you
come on let's go
the new cast of that teaser looked
killer uh maybe even literally i really
hope not uh mike flanagan always puts
together an exceptional cast the
midnight club reunites him with some of
his most frequent acting collaborators
which includes samantha sloane zack
gilford anara simone
plus igb rigney uh matt bedell and of
course raul coley it also stars some new
flanigan faces like iman benson ruth cod
and aya furukawa also adia suryan
subcoda and william chris sumter as the
titular midnight club based off the
novel of the same name by christopher
pike mike flanagan's the midnight club
is coming in netflix soon speaking of
scary stories this next one is chilling
and i am already afraid you need to take
some deep breaths
horror is your thing yeah
it really gets me it knows how to make
me scared
coming from thailand school tales is an
eight episode horror series inspired by
eight horrifying comic stories during
the day the school belongs to the
students but at night
it's unfortunately a different story
isn't that always the case
today we have three first book clips
from three different episodes uh let's
take a look at the first one from the
episode titled a walk in school which
already is scary to me oh god
you think
foreign
i i don't know i'm with tom i feel so
bad for tom you know i identify with tom
i gotta say i as a lover of horror uh
i'm not spending any nights in a
supposedly haunted school gosh and the
title was so misleading a walk in school
that felt like a safe space i think it's
a raw doll book but i'm getting murdered
at the end of it i mean you know
in a walk walk-in school two students
announced that they will host the live
broadcast to expose that all the
frightening tales are just lies which
why
but the quest pushes the boys deeper and
deeper into the unknown and each door
they open leads them further into the
abyss of hell
poor tongue man wow that is not
ambiguous at all
our next clip is from the episode
vengeful spell where the discovery of a
murdered student reveals a more
sinister secret well high schoolers ever
learn to stop seeking out angry spirits
you know i gotta be honest
i don't i don't want them to who are we
kidding
like let's let's let's take a look
[Music]
do
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that took such a weird turn i i was not
expecting that i gotta say i cut
somebody off in traffic the other day
and i
curses really freaked me out man you
never know
oh my gosh is it that easy do you think
i mean i
you write something on your foot i guess
i mean i certainly i don't know what i
don't know what i would say in english i
curse
you think you just gotta believe it i
mean you know if you mean it hard enough
yeah i guess well i mean the last clip
we have today is from an episode called
lunch oh good yeah actually i am kind of
hungry so
perfect timing yeah i don't think you're
gonna want to eat after you learn the
secret ingredient aunt jong is using to
make her rice and curry so delicious um
so let's see maybe we'll be hungry who
knows
let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
oh
i i don't think i want to know what's in
that pot why does he want to know which
one is so bad he's being a little rude
okay here's to the ma'am here's what i'm
picking up from this is that you can
never trust a live streamer because this
is this seems to be a reoccurring dress
but see look at all the cameras live
streams i'm telling you don't trust them
no way i'm never live streaming ever
again this horror anthology from five
star productions is coming soon at
netflix so stay tuned for more
information and now
it's time for another new series we have
a first look at a new sci-fi drama the
imperfects where 20 somethings get
turned into monsters by evil scientists
against their wills the cast recorded us
a special message to set up an exciting
surprise so let's take a look
hello everyone hey guys hello everyone
hi my name is rihanna jagpal and i play
abby singh i play dr sydney burke i play
tail dye and i play juan ruiz at the
upcoming netflix series the imperfects
some things i have in common with tilda
singing is also my medicine however i'm
more of a shower singer than tilda abby
is a brilliant scientist and i think
that her and i are very similar in the
sense that there is nothing that can get
in the way of us helping the people that
we love i relate to sydney in uh the
perfectionist kind of way where
everything has its place and his need
and is organized yeah she's pretty
meticulous and i think so am i just ask
my husband why do i relate to with juan
well we are both very talented drawers
we're both very extremely handsome he's
from mexico yotamisu mexico and we both
have a very very terrifying monster
insiders that we can't control
well that's too much information anyways
fans can expect a lot from this show
there's so many surprises and twists and
turns every episode opens with a bang he
has suspense he has monsters he has evil
scientists unexpected love interest some
good old passion
i'm very very excited for people to see
this show it's a whole fun fantastic
world where
you just kind of get to lose yourself
and have a good time season one
of the imperfect don't miss it you're
gonna love it
[Music]
do you remember dr sarkov
he experimented on all of us without our
permission
you
me tilda
we all had
adverse reactions
we're not even human anymore technically
no
well that's [ __ ] great
we're not human what are we
you're
[Music]
that looks freaking sick yeah that's
that's definitely got my interest picked
i yeah the shot of the werewolf thing
with the spikes yeah freaking awesome
plus i mean i i love a story about
suppressing a monster in your 20s i feel
like that's
that's widely relatable yeah i'm excited
yucky man that guy's killing it i can't
wait the whole cast looks crazy
impressive i can't wait to see what
they've got that i plus i mean yeah the
premise the premises is killer
i'm sorry i'm gonna stop with these puns
maybe maybe i'm gonna it's a soft
promise um we also have some exclusive
posters from the imperfects showing each
of the characters uh check this one out
oh yeah she looks very cool all three of
them i don't know
there's a rock star too i like a good
rock star the rock star is good
everybody's artsy and it's good
poor kid i feel like he's just so
confused going through all this like
really does it like he's a werewolf
doesn't know it figuring it out wakes up
naked in the woods and covered in blood
your 20s are hard like your 20s are hard
you know hey
why can't we just normalize that all
right 20s are hard
i already know this is going to be my
favorite character
i just like it she's are you [ __ ]
kidding me she just seems cool i'm down
she looks really tough yeah these are
definitely not the college clicks that
i'm used to
the imperfex has an all-star lineup of
inaki godoy morgan taylor campbell
rihanna jagpal and italia ritchie be
sure to check out this brand new series
only on netflix if maybe we should or
can we move on to something a little
sweeter
no more horror and scaring me constantly
you've been you've done so well so far
but hey i mean that's a good idea did
you see season one of sweet tooth i did
i loved it uh i can't wait for season
two as well oh my god me too uh what
kind of a hybrid do you think it'd be
i'd obviously have to be a hawk
considering all of the wordplay that
i've been getting yeah
that's my dad that's my bad
if there's anyone out there like me
i need to find them
[Music]
it's so wholesome man that kid really is
the cutest he's so adorable well season
two of sweet tooth was announced in 2021
and the cast has been hard at work
bringing to life all the latest
adventures of gus jeff and bear
mentioned you're really excited about
season two and lucky for you we actually
have a very special update from the cast
who's shooting in new zealand
this is a story
a story of a very special group of
people
who found themselves at the end
of filming season two of sweet tooth
everybody that is a wrap
it's a wrap of season two of sweet tooth
good
yeah it's been a long journey and it's
been very hard work but it's been
amazing fun and i can't wait to share
with you what happens in season two
the stakes are higher the battles are
bigger
uh the mean guys are meaner you're in
for a treat
it's gonna be an amazing adventure
but this isn't the end of their story
and i can't wait
to see what happens next
man the mean guys are meaner
how long have you had that candy bar
i've had my back pocket for a while i
literally just said i was hungry but i
mean if you haven't seen sweet tooth
you're missing out it's the most
uplifting show about the apocalypse i've
i've ever seen so wholesome it is it's
amazing and the incredible series is
based on the dc comic book series the
same name by jeff lemire and it's
produced by robert downey jr and susan
downey at the end of season one we were
left wondering if jeff and amy would
save the hybrids yeah and will gus be
reunited with his mom which we have to
know uh but we have to wait until season
two to find out but you can catch season
one right now and be sure to follow
sweet tooth netflix and netflix geeked
for all the season two updates yeah
that's a good bar give me some of that
for you sorry
so uh
look what i just found in my pocket
whoa
what is that mysterious object
conveniently placed in your pocket i
know some kind of key
whatever you think you understand about
those keys
you don't
i don't think the masses understand but
i think i do
this is the key to unlock the season
three teaser trailer for lock and key
oh my god are you serious yeah it's
gonna work absolutely it's the third and
final season i believe that this is
exactly how you do it actually no it's
gonna work nothing makes more sense than
this if i do it a million times it's
gonna play the teaser just keep going
yeah i almost got it we're gonna unlock
the teaser and find out okay
my past is always with us well you can
try and run away
but
it's always there
we've been tangled up in this for years
who the hell are you
your captain
and something more
this is our house those keys belong to
us
oh
[Music]
that looks so ominous i'm so invested
was that when he was screaming in front
of the angel wing yeah i mean what the
heck was that
i mean i'm more invested in what's going
on with with the well lady i really want
to know you're ugly what is going on
i'm just i'm so curious i mean to have
this kind of power at your fingertips is
so crazy i want to know what it all
means yeah what it leads to yeah and
what the significance of like key house
is to the family i just i'm so i'm i'm
invested i'm very invested i can't wait
see more jackson but you know it's from
the shore runners carlton hughes and
meredith avril locking key is an
adaptation of the best-selling comic
book series by joe hill and gabriel
rodriguez season two ended with a pretty
massive cliffhanger a new threat and the
most dangerous yet looms in matheson in
the upcoming season the log family will
uncover more magic within keyhouse to
take on this new threat in an epic final
battle and you will not want to miss it
and i think i speak for all the fans
when i say we are sad to see it end but
can't wait to find out what happens the
fandom has been guessing and hoping and
predicting all kinds of outcomes for
this series it's been all over social
media don't miss the final season of
lock and key when it premieres on
netflix on august 10th wow we actually
get a date
that's pretty sick oh we're getting
we're getting fed today oh yeah and not
just from whatever is in aunt john's uh
pot
exactly next up we have a series that's
making a triumphant return for a second
season at a magical boarding school
where magical teens hone their magical
skills magical problems always seem to
come up funny i love magical boarding
schools and we're talking about fate the
wink saga
i always knew your path wouldn't be like
everyone else's
[Music]
but i can't wait to see who you become
[Applause]
pretty cool fire eyes it's getting me
inspired inspired by the beloved
animated show fate the wing saga follows
bloom a ferry with fire powers which is
kind of arguably the best kind of power
i'm gonna say it's pretty sick yeah when
she enrolls in a magical boarding school
at alfia yeah with the help of her new
fairy friends stella aisha tara and musa
season one sees bloom learning more
about her past while the team faces off
against terrifying threats of the burned
ones for somebody with firepower
this might not be the best thing ever
now am i the problem am i
she's fighting burn to people it seems
like they already got the fire on me
yeah i feel like she's maybe how do you
overcome that maybe she could get like a
buddy with some water powers and they
can like steam them ice like hot steamy
movie
spirals
and we've got a fan favorite that's
finally joining the cast of fate the
wing saga in season two flora played by
paulina chavez yeah fate fans you're in
luck because we're able to reveal the
first look at the earth fairy flora in
the season two clip
held her on route i'm pretty sure he's
tried it can you remember what the bites
from devon's body look like
multiple incisions a pattern
might narrow it down it doesn't matter
this is a useless exercise dad already
said he's not going to let you help well
i'm very convincing more so than
rosalind because she was very clear no
students were allowed near devin dad
won't do anything she doesn't approve of
pathetic as that is you need to lay off
it and you need to get back to the
school grounds
it's dangerous out there i'll be done
when i'm done
[Music]
whoever you are
i come out very very slowly
[Music]
[Music]
miss me
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was so wholesome that was such a
beautiful moment of friendship i love it
you almost don't realize how terrifying
those like poison ivy esque powers would
i thought i was going to get attacked by
vines i know they started growing
beautiful flowers went the whole other
direction
looks like there's a new arrival to
alpha yeah she's very floral and uh fans
are pumped to see flora join the fun in
season two and paulina nails this role
floor will join bloom stella aisha tara
and musa in season two as they fight to
save althea from a new evil threat that
threatens the inhabitants why can't they
just catch a break man i know why can't
they just hang out
and burn some stuff give each other high
you could grow back with the earth
fairies between the burnings yeah you
know you don't have to wait too long to
find out what happens next we have
exciting news that season two is coming
to netflix in fall 2022. that's really
soon it's going to be hard to prioritize
these which the watch order yeah
everything is coming out so quickly i'm
really excited about
this this one's going to be your number
one priority i know come on give it to
you none fans yeah you asking and asking
and asking i think jacob's personally
been harassing the netflix team
asking for any teas of season two
fortunately the wait is over
i love in action sequences when they
speed up the hits yes
that's so sick well if you're into
creepy mythology badass superpowers and
intense fight scenes between nuns which
yeah who wouldn't love that uh then this
series is definitely made for you i'm so
pumped
warrior none follows an orphaned teen
named ava who wakes up in a morgue i
mean like universal experience
with a new lease on life and a divine
artifact embedded in her back and
discovers she possesses superpowers as
the chosen halo bearer for a secret sect
of demon hunting nuns it's the best type
of nun i wonder where that secret sect
practices and if i could go to this i
want to find like that section of
catholic history yes
that would be like i want to know what
what codex they got
we have a first look at season two so
let's check it out
i know you want to know what happened
tell you the truth i'm still figuring it
out myself
first i was dead
then i was alive
then i got tricked
and then the devil kicked my ass
still there's a thousand items left on
my life to-do list
but you can't check them off if you're
dead
[Music]
[Applause]
no one in history has ever defeated
adriel and lived
welcome
looks like we're gonna have to make
history
i told you that i would learn to swim
[Music]
wow thank you warrior nun
you know i don't i'm just saying
jesus walked on water she was fully
sprinting she was sprinting if i'd have
known that that's what it was like to be
a nun i would have been a lot more
interested yeah damn i would have joined
a long time ago where's the sign-up
sheet i feel like we really missed out
the pitch that was given to me was very
different
but everyone's favorite demon fighting
nuns are back in season two of warrior
none for more action and updates check
out netflix geek on instagram i can't
believe how many first looks and big
reveals we've already shown you today
and we're just getting started
we're very lucky we're very lucky people
later today we've got everyone's
favorite of course the brelis
together to debut an exclusive clip from
the umbrella academy season three
premiere and preview what we have to
look forward to i'm so excited for this
yes and we will also finally finally
finally
going to find out when the sandman is
premiering on netflix when neil gaiman
tom sturridge and they cast it down with
felicia day to talk about the
long-awaited adaptation
that's gonna be sick i'm so excited
but first we're not done just yet it's
time for
jacob shadow and bone heck yeah did you
watch season one i mean
i did uh and it was a global sensation
and i'm still fighting with people
online about whether i'm team darklina
melino or janulina
i mean we do need to get you off tumblr
we have talked about that we have my
moody moment okay
during last year's geek week we
announced that shadow bone will be
coming back for season two and since
then we've gotten some long-awaited
casting news that jack wolf will be
playing the final crow wylin and patrick
gibson is playing the heartthrob nikolai
lansdov and badass says anna leong
brophy and louis tan are playing the
dynamic duo tamar antolia but i mean
the fans we the fans
we want another update we need one and
well j stoops
you're in luck because we have a very
special video from the cast
[Music]
hello greetings in honor of netflix's
geek week we thought we would share some
exciting news with you we've officially
wrapped season two of shadow and bone
and we cannot wait for you to see what
we've been up to really sad that it's
over we're also very excited for you
guys to see it oh we can't give too much
away at this time we wanted to answer a
few questions to keep you guys guessing
on what's to come
[Music]
love power heartbreak heart rending
heart pounding swashbuckling full
of
life bigger
bolder
and better action-packed epic and
protesting
it's it's just gotta be hashtag guilty
guilty
underestimated angry
fierce
traumatized but also the best
[Music]
come on it's not even a question
come on
jasper skills with pistols please i'm
gonna have to go with tamar's axes sorry
jesper come on guys that's a no-brainer
is axes all the way come on you're
speaking to a crow crow club all the way
i'm just in crow club definitely the
crow club uh drinking gambling sounds
great year in hellgate all day long i
think i'd do all right in there make a
few friends across the board for sure um
you know there's things you'll see in
hellgate that you can't
[Music]
there's
waffles
100
that's gonna be pancakes pancakes
a lovely vegan crepe
we are all so
so excited and we cannot wait for you to
see season two happy geeked week and
we'll see you on the other side of the
fault
that's a wrap
[Music]
did that i just wish i had a british
accent
i wish i was a part of them
it's so sweet
i like how it was like
across the fold or spend a year
and it's like pancakes or waffles
i love it based on the hidden novels by
leigh bardugo shadow and bone has an
all-star cast of jessie may lee ben
barnes archie renault as well as freddie
carter amita simon and kit young kanesh
polaroid when i mean be sure to follow
uh shadow and bone on instagram and
netflix geeked for all the season two
updates
are you ready to introduce the next show
do you need a breather
because it's a big one yes i've
recovered from my shadow and bone fandom
uh i am more than excited to introduce
the first look at season four of
manifest yes and we were so stoked when
netflix announced manifest will be
coming back for its fourth and final
season yeah fans can't wait to find out
what actually happened to the passengers
on flight 828 and we now have a special
message from josh dallas so take it away
josh
hey it's josh we're working hard here
filming the final season of manifest
there is a two-part final season coming
soon to netflix but in the meantime
here's a clip coming your way
[Music]
cherry blossoms there you are
uh
so
[Music]
wow
what did it say i mean it's childhood
huh yeah yeah i mean i'm more
preoccupied with the fact that he's
carved into his arm yeah
but it definitely ladies
i mean i don't know about you but when i
you know do my
investigating investigating into you
know the docks the last thing i expect
is an arm to reach out to me in a
shipping container i'm just so curious
like how long that dude's been there
exactly why caught well you couldn't
have carved that on the side of the wall
i'm always and this guy went all in
carving it on his arm that's intense
must be important the
shining light coming out of the shipping
container
what's going on there and dark inside i
don't know yeah it seems that they're
trying to hoodwink us exactly yeah
there's something i'm you know what i'm
gonna go ahead and call it now we're
smarter than that something amiss is
happening here yeah there is something
amiss we've we figured it out there's
there's a mystery here
you heard it here first so get ready for
the epic conclusion of manifest by
re-watching seasons one through three
maybe that maybe your answer is there
yeah what's on the arm
but up next we have something a little
more my speed a treat from our friends
at vikings valhalla
you are here because
you
are
my gosh
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah that is badass wow
that was that's pretty sick that was
quite violent oh my god i yeah it's
pretty pretty pretty badass it's giving
me a hawk flashback i like it i'm
feeling invigorated that is what it
reminded me of i wish i wish my signs
were shaving i'm like mohawk right now
the evolution of the original series
vikings was a massive hit when it
dropped on netflix earlier this year and
already a second season has been
announced while we can't show you what's
in store for leif freitas and harold in
season two just yet we do have a season
one blooper reel to help tide you over i
love blooper reels i'm so excited uh
let's check out some of the last behind
the making of vikings valhalla
school school vikings we heard that it
was geeked week
before we set off to battle towards our
next season we wanted to stop in and say
thank you thank you so much you helped
us to become a top 10 series
in 91 countries which my brain can't
even comprehend and we are so excited to
be able to bring you not one but two
more seasons for vikings
as a thank you
we wanted to share with you some top
secret info about the next season
firstly
there's not gonna be any fighting no
axes no swords no arrows
we're done with that secondly
no more romance
they uh they said it wasn't clicking and
finally pagans
and the christians will become the
greatest of friends and there will be
peace everywhere
now all jokes aside a viking wouldn't
come to geeks week without a gift so we
offer up the greatest gift of a video of
us making complete and utter fools of
ourselves please enjoy for the first
time ever
a glorious reel of vikings valhalla
bloopers
[Music]
did they say actually they did say
action yes
[Music]
oh
no
let me do that again and do that again
i'm gonna do that again but i believe i
could be of service to you here in
england should you cry should you
would you like to start i'd love to
start again let me do that again
wrong mind
[Music]
is my hair okay like this
[Music]
okay yeah it is now
[Music]
mr bacon i slipped
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's great you know i've always i've
always thought that the best way to
approach getting on a horse is to just
yeah just like
what is just like dead fish onto it
i'm sure the horse would love that
it looks like the cast had an amazing
time yeah you just flopped sideways on
the horizon
yeah jacob's got some tips for you guys
yeah there we go well hey if you like
vikings and you can't get enough of
period action adventure shows then
you're gonna really enjoy this next
sword and sandal series that's a good
sword and sandal yeah
it's a good genre yeah this isn't
written i just came up with i am
prolific
we're of course talking about barbarians
foreign
there's just
there's just something about dudes angry
screaming in the camera with their arms
out you know i mean it speaks to me i
don't know what it is it's like it's
vicarious you know we live in such a
world where like if you get frustrated
with someone the best you can do is just
be like oh okay like a little passive
aggression in your day but apparently uh
there used to be other options you know
what the next time you're at starbucks
you should try that jc just in this
order
pull out my battle axe and start
screaming yeah exactly well barbarians
is about a roman officer torn between
the mighty empire that raised him and
his own tribal people which leads to an
epic historical clash season one ended
with a massive battle of the romans
ambushing the barbarians and i mean
what's gonna happen next we have a sneak
peek at season two
[Music]
the romans are going to fall
i mean spoiler alert but uh the romans
did not meet america
romans things don't end well for the
romans
but i do love to see a woman holding an
axe i'm not gonna lie there you go you
heard it here first on geek week's folks
barbarian season two is finally coming
to netflix this fall this fall
everything's this fall i know it's crazy
well you can check out season one now on
netflix if you haven't already and if
you have i mean
why not just rewatch it yeah prepare for
the fall yeah up next we have a series
that's become a global sensation based
on the webtoon now at our school we have
all of us are dead
[Applause]
i love zombies
all of us are dead as a coming-of-age
story set in catastrophic circumstances
where a group of loyal friends band
together to overcome zombies uh and
crushes and loss and bullies cass got
together uh for a special message to
help us celebrate some of the big news
all of us are dead is coming back for
season
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
i will regardless of how into zombies
you are i think it's safe to say that
all of us are here for all of us are
dead
all right everybody our time with you is
almost at an end so you know what's
coming up next it's gotta be good uh but
don't go anywhere even though jacob and
i may soon be uh saying our farewell uh
felicia day is gonna be sitting down
with the cast of the umbrella academy
and the sandman and revealing some
exciting exclusives from the upcoming
series meanwhile our friends at most got
together with the cats the first kill
and put on a vampire ball how do i get
invited to that i need to go to a
vampire ball uh be a vampire
and i live pretty recommended i missed
the first requirement okay and that's
just day one of geek week we have four
more days of big reveals cast reunions
and
stranger things
we gotta get you as a sound guy like
you're really good i could talk you're a
one man foley artist come on netflix
hook it up
uh okay but we have promised some big
news before we sign off yes and for
those of you who have been up in the
netflix geek comments demanding more
news on alice in borderland
your time is now it's been two long
years since allison borderland first
shopped on netflix and in the time since
it's ranked in the top 10 in over 70
countries twice
the second time after the release of the
mega hit squid game and the upcoming
season is sure to be incredible for
those of you who aren't familiar let's
take a look back at season one
is
foreign
foreign
[Music]
see
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh my god that looks so good so intense
if you haven't watched it yet allison
borderland is a japanese sci-fi thriller
about gamers who end up in a parallel
world where they have to play for
survival and the upcoming season is sure
to be incredible just take a look at
these images of the stars kento yamazaki
and tao sushiya
oh no i mean they don't they don't look
thrilled it's so dire it's so dire kento
amazaki as the video game obsessed rioja
riso i feel like he's looking at the
game master oh you think it's a big
reveal here and tao sushiya as the
mountain climbing obsessed yuzuha usaki
this is a battle to to get one final
winner that's the winner right there
if you love squid game kingdom or
hellbound you're sure to love alice in
borderland
hey uh jacob by the way are you a fan of
one piece
come on now come on give it to me
i had a feeling one piece is one of the
biggest manga
okay
it's been give me some lessons and anime
of all time i can't believe it has over
1 000 episodes yeah it's pretty nuts and
luffy's quest to be the pirate king is
coming to live action in the new netflix
series starring anyaki godoy emily rudd
mckenyou jacob romero gibson and tas
skylar the cast has been hard at work in
south africa bringing the world of one
piece to life and to get a sense of the
show we got an exclusive behind the
scenes look at a truly massive set
so uh let's roll the clip
hello everyone i'm miyaki godoy and i
play luffy in one piece
hi i'm steve mayeda i'm the showrunner
of one piece and i'm matt owens
showrunner and as you can see we're here
in south africa bringing one piece to
life uh we'd like to show you a sneak
peek of some of our massive sets it's
the biggest one piece fan it's been
really exciting seeing some of my
favorite places from the manga become a
reality all right enough talk roll the
clip
roll it
oda's world is so unique seeing all of
this stuff in person being able to reach
out and touch it has just been
such an experience our crews down here
in south africa are incredible and it's
been so rewarding to see
them
taking oda's world and bringing it to
life
because of the level of detail and
attention that goes into all of these
sets they take a good amount of time i
mean right now we're building arlon's
map room and it's already been a couple
of weeks but it's a big build because
it's a really important location a lot
of drama goes down in there a lot of
action goes down in there so we have to
get it just right
i love all the ships but bratier is
massive it is iconic it is surrounded by
floating docks along with a bar inside
the fish mouth which is going to be
zoro's favorite spot in those episodes
at the end of it all i'm most excited to
just be able to share this world with
old fans and new we get to go to work
every day and walk on these massive sets
and see these characters come to life
it's a really special
experience and a privilege and we can't
wait to share with you
oh my i can't believe they built all of
that i mean to see those sets in live
action is just it's got to be so
exciting for a long time one piece fans
that was our first look at the baratier
that's so cool
i mean the attention to detail
everything we saw it's so intricate it's
so incredible yeah and we actually have
some exciting casting news for one piece
joma umuela will play nogico celeste
lutz will be kaya and alexander manianis
will be clawhadore and we'll have
langley kirkwood as captain morgan plus
craig fairbreast as chef zeph
and stephen ward as mihawk if you can't
wait to hit the high seas be sure to
follow one piece netflix and netflix
geeked on instagram and twitter but
don't set sail just yet because our next
title is something you're not going to
want to miss yeah coming july 14th evil
has evolved that's right we're talking
about resident evil the legendary
franchise redefined for netflix set 14
years after a deadly virus caused a
global apocalypse
as that happens
resident evil sees jade wesker the
daughter of albert wesker fighting for
survival in a world overrun by the
bloodthirsty infected she's haunted by
her past in new raccoon city and her
father's chilling connections to the
umbrella corporation but most
importantly uh what happened to her
sister wait
what happened to her sister
well we'll see
because right here at geek week we're
getting the very first trailer for
resident evil
they said the world would end in 2036.
but they were wrong
the world ended a long time ago
umbrella
a company besieged by a scandal is now
trying to reinvent itself
[Music]
the old umbrella made mistakes the
things we're working on today they're
gonna change the world
[Music]
the drug contains the t-virus
the t-virus can make monsters
billions will die
everyone keep your mouth shut
[ __ ] it
is complicated
this
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
the old-timey music that makes
everything really eerie why does it
always make it so creepy yeah it's such
a good juxtaposition really is but like
resident evil had such a hold on like
when i was in high school oh my god i
could feel like 2000's ish just like
when like milo jovovich just owned the
world but i gotta say like this the
property always had so much potential
and i just feel like oh my god like this
this looks like the best possible
version of this story i'm so excited um
lance redick leads the cast as albert
wesker and is joined by ella balinska
and tamara smart it also stars paolo la
nunez siena agudong and adeline rudolph
it seriously just gives us the best of
what resident evil has to offer badass
heroes insane creatures a fight for
survival and a deep mystery to unravel
that'll be plagiar i mean you know how
we love a mystery we can also
reveal this creepy new poster for the
show is that a liquor that's badass
it is uh you can see the full new poster
over at resident evil netflix on
instagram and if you want you can dive
deeper and find out more about resident
evil and the umbrella corporation head
to umbrella is joy.com it's a very
misleading
url come on it's a family-friendly
corporation
okay this is our last big reveal of the
day before we send you on your way jacob
do you want to take this one absolutely
jay stoops uh we all know you love the
first german original series dark as
much as we did the creators of the
incredible mind-bending german sci-fi
drama are coming back with an even
wilder series we're talking about 1899 a
brand new thriller that follows the
mysterious circumstances around the
voyage of an immigrant ship from europe
to new york
the passengers all different backgrounds
and nationalities are united by their
hopes and dreams for a new century and
their future abroad oh this makes this
so sad because they discover a second
ship adrift on the open sea that have
gone missing for months and their
journey takes an unexpected turn i don't
know why they go to the you never chip
you never take the detour like you never
take the details you should just went
straight there to the promised land and
it would have been fun it just
you hate to see it happen to good people
let's take a look
hi i'm emily beacham i play moira from
1899 and i can't wait for you to enjoy
this show
i am wire franklin
today is october 19 1899.
why do you think they're all here
they're all running away from something
why else would someone want to go
somewhere different
wake up
people are oblivious to reality
they only see what they want to see
and all they have to do
shift their perspective
to see the full scope of things
hi my name is janjeer i'm the showrunner
and head writer
of dark
elf dog
director and executive producer of 1899.
dark was not about action at all but
this is really an action show with a lot
of
violence
beating running screaming
someone at netflix told us about the
volume technology to be honest after
three seasons of dark we were a bit
tired of doing it in a very traditional
way
netflix was super helpful from the
beginning because they said this might
be the future and could be really
interesting for your project
how would you describe the volume to
somebody who knows nothing about it i
tried to describe it to my son and i
just said
it's like the biggest tv you'll ever see
and we just act in front of it it looks
real it really looks real and that of
course it's a huge help for us so we
don't have to travel to to the desert
nor to the north pole nor to the
glaciers and stuff you can change that
within a minute
it would be a totally different
experience if we're doing this on green
screen it just illuminates
like literally everything you see the
whole landscape in front of you and the
lighting and so you're really looking at
the sea
it's a lot of prep work it is a lot of
frustration at the beginning because it
is literally a new way of filmmaking
we get to be pioneers we get to work on
things we have no idea about
i think it's going to be exciting to
watch if the audience actually loves
this new puzzle too as they liked dark
and if they will figure out what this
show is actually really about
what's up with that black goo
and the girl getting yanked back and the
bodies everywhere get a thing
uh if you like mysterious period pieces
be sure to check out 1899. all right
geeked week
that's it for us we covered so much we
laughed we screamed we cried we dreamed
all about these amazing upcoming netflix
series both new and returning but up
next we'll be chatting with the cast of
the sandman yes the sandman and yes
you're finally finding out when it's
coming and felicia day sits down with
the cast of the umbrella academy for an
exclusive sneak peek at season three we
haven't even begun to scratch the
surface of all the incredible content to
come yeah stay right here
hello fellow geeks my name is mason
alexander park and i play desire in the
sandman and here are five reasons why
you should be excited to see the show
the first reason you should watch the
sandman is because i am in it
no it's actually because the cast is
pretty remarkable they are a insane sexy
group of people
the second reason is the representation
in this show is pretty outstanding it is
an iconically diverse group of people
and i couldn't be more proud of the
representation that is in the sandman
universe
the third reason is neil friggin gaiman
i mean he is an iconic storyteller this
is his baby this is his world and i
cannot wait for y'all to see what he has
been cooking up with us
the fourth reason is it looks and it
feels just like the comics there was a
point where we were bringing panels from
the comic books onto set in order to
compare and contrast as we were building
out scenes
the fifth and final reason
is the endless i think we are the
ultimate dysfunctional television family
and
what better to watch it is the comic
book version of the sopranos
thanks for watching netflix geeked and
i'll see you in the sandman
sandman is the story of the place that
we go when we close our eyes at night
and it's called the dreaming
and the dreaming
is ruled by morpheus
for 32 years
anybody who read sandman read the comics
that world is ending
i'm here at shepparton studios and i'm
getting to see what happens when you
bring dreams to life
i'm someone who is
an obsessive sandman fan it's an awesome
responsibility because it's something
that is so
beloved
i read the sandman graphic novels so i
knew
that i
simply had to be involved in this
project because
something truly unique was going to
happen the sets are vast great amount of
detail and care has been put into
how it's being brought to life
holy [ __ ]
this is amazing
we're in the undercroft
our art department are set decorators
our production designers
they are wizards they are absolute
magicians and to see what they've
conjured here
it's like walking around
inside
your own dream
this is sandman being made for people
who love sandman
by
people who love sandman
and i cannot wait until people see this
[Music]
tonight we will achieve what no one was
even attempted we will summon
and imprison
death
[Music]
i give you a coin made from a stone
i give you a feather
together
death
as family
desire
destiny
despair
which one have i got
dream
you're gonna need all the help you can
get
[Music]
want to stay in the know about your
favorite netflix shows and films you'll
find news videos interviews and more on
taboo the official netflix site to help
find and fuel your fandom stranger
things the grey man the umbrella academy
and more make peak week last all year on
netflix.com
we would achieve what no one was even
attempted we will summon
and imprison
death
what's up geek tweak i am felicia day
and i am so excited to be here for this
very special geek week panel where we
will finally answer the long-awaited
question
when is the sandman coming to netflix
death
press family
desire
destiny
despair
we have some awesome surprises in store
for you but first i couldn't do this
panel without the three people i am
about to introduce
alan heinberg showrunner for the sandman
and the man we have to thank for finally
bringing this incredible world to life
tom sturridge who plays the enigmatic
endless dream and neil gaiman the
brilliant mind behind the comic i do
um the first issues of sandman came out
over three decades ago and they have had
such an impact on pop culture what do
you think continues to be so resonant
about the story neil
i think the story
works because
you know
young neil gaiman had some kind of idea
of what he was doing and was
desperate to tell
a story that would last
and also was desperate to tell a story
that would keep being printed in a comic
month to month
because he wanted to do this more than
any anything in the world
and so it had everything that i loved
and cared about
and it was willing not to be the same
thing and i think that weirdness the
fact that
sandman isn't just one thing
but it grows it changes if you like
one bit of sandman you may or may not
like the next bit but you'll love the
bit after that actually is responsible
for why
three decades later it still has life
people still care about the story alan
um how did you approach adapting this
comic to the tv series because it is
it's a beast of so many different things
i approached it primarily as a fan i
fell in love with it when i was in
college i was buying it monthly
um
on in comic book stores so i steeped
myself in the comics again i read all of
neil's original scripts and then i got
to work very very very closely with neil
um bringing it to life so but primarily
as a as somebody who loved it and was
desperate to see a version of it yeah
primarily as a fan tom um
you are incredible too hey hey what's up
what are the endless and how do they fit
into the story of the sandman
wow what are the endless the endless uh
mysterious collection of beings seven
siblings the
children of the cosmic entities night
and time
they're the
anthropomorphic embodiment of certain
forces
powerful human forces in order of age
there's
destiny
death
dream
destruction desire despair and delirium
and what's amazing about them and what i
love about them is that despite this
kind of extraordinary fantastical
description they are
like a normal family in that they're
riddled with dysfunction and it's that
dysfunction which propels our story and
our narrative and that's
how they're a part of it you know when i
first came to america
people would say to me you know we love
sandman and uh
and we love
that you've made this dysfunctional
family
and i've never heard the term before so
i was like what is a dysfunctional
family and they would explain and
eventually i went oh
that's what in england we call it a
family
exactly
which one have i got
dream
you're gonna need all the help you can
get
that perfectly sets us up to introduce
our next round of guests vivienne at
champong who plays lucian the librarian
jenna coleman who plays demon hunting
joanna constantine
winesu semonyai who plays rose walker
and boyd holbrook who plays the
corinthian
thank you so much for being here so many
of you
dream goes on a journey through many
different stories this season there is
this huge cast as we could see have you
all been together like this all at once
before
i don't know
no
last time we've just met
yeah the story is so varied and it goes
so many places with so many actors it's
kind of funny to think you're such
important characters and you've never
met that's blows my mind
this cast alan is just truly incredible
can you talk about finding the right
performers for these roles um we had the
most extraordinary casting directors
lucinda syson and natasha vincent and
meli nagler at warner brothers who's in
charge of casting there and their tastes
and their instincts were incredible but
mostly i think
neil did the work for us um once word
got out that you know the sandman this
new gaming property that's been out for
as long as it has and has as many fans
as it has once where it got out we had
people coming to us saying may i be in
the sandman
a lot of times we would start talking
about you know who do we see in this
role
and uh we got very lucky in that we were
talking about jenna from the very very
beginning because neil and i are huge
jenna coleman fans and we got very lucky
um that the pandemic you know allowed
her the space in her in her diary to
join us
so it happened a lot of different ways
um
but we got very lucky yeah vivian uh
lucian is such a pivotal character for
dream can you talk about developing that
dynamic with tom uh when i met tom
he's so lovely and warm and open
and then he just completely transforms
into morpheus and is incredible and you
can just tell that he really knows this
character
because he has just embodied him
so beautifully and it just made my job
as an actor really easy
um
he's a dream no pun intended but um
literally as an actor a dream to work
with because he just gives you so much
he's so generous
so it was a pretty
easy thing for me to do with him boyd
the corinthian is a fan favorite from
the comics let's talk about those
eyes and how you approach bringing the
corinthian to life who is he and what is
his role in the show
yeah the corinthian is
basically
the metamorphosis or the your worst
nightmare in the matrix of the dreaming
created by morpheus um
when i first
heard about this
and talking to my friends about it they
were like oh you're going to play the
corinthian
it seemed like a larger-than-life really
outrageous character but the more and i
talked about it with alan and
and neil it seemed like it was a person
that you
would welcome into your home
the the sort of kindness and the ease
that he would put you in it's more
hannibal than like a like a flamboyant
joker character
and it was just very hard to
calibrate
being
you know under these glasses
and just how to
lot of acting is done with your eyes so
that for me was something to adjust to
yeah well there's a folksy quiet menace
to you that is very people are going to
be very excited to see take that as a
call it is i'm from alabama
[Laughter]
jenna you are no uh stranger to epic
franchises what appealed to you about
the role of joanna constantine
just from the first reading of the
script um
it was the the
the character just was so fleshed out
the voice the everything kind of
came to me straight away like a
the idea of her being this you know this
lone kind of ranger in the world with
this tough exterior and her cynicism and
kind of rhyness and wit to kind of not
let anybody close um yeah quite a
tortured a tortured soul like with a big
compassionate heart hidden somewhere
underneath yeah and an amazing trench
coat and a great trench coat that was
that was the main reason obviously
but i do have a treat for you in our
first exclusive geek week reveal we can
share the brand new character posters
for joanna constantine the corinthian
and some exclusive sandman posters let
us take a look
[Laughter]
what happened oh yeah i love that god
that looks cool beautiful
what's the hell i found out
[Laughter]
um yeah and the trench coat how is it
seeing that is that kind of cool to see
it in real life
i'm very happy we've got the we've got
the uh the crucifixion yeah yeah yeah
yeah well you're really rocking the
trench coat they're gonna be a lot of
cosplay
for sure
for those of you at home who want a
closer look you can check out these
posters over on the sandman official on
instagram and of course at netflix
geeked
uh vanessa this is your first series
role as rose walker and she's such a
pivotal character in the sandman can you
tease a little bit of your story and
what it was like to work with tom um so
rose walker is a regular 21 year old who
has lost her parents
and
she's just alone in the world and she
wants to find her brother jed
um
she wants a sense of
normalcy back in her life
along the way she meets uh she meets
morpheus and they work on you know
trying to get that going and tom is tom
is uh great really great to work with
and what was really nice was how we
played with
um
morpheus and like the relationship
between them the dynamic
how and the change that dream had over
their interaction you guys have an
incredible incredible effect on each
other and it just blows my mind that
this is your first role it's a big big
set to step into how was that for you it
was great this is a great you know
series to have as my first series role
nerve-wracking in the beginning and then
i eased into it the script was really um
in the beginning even when i was
auditioning it was something that it
made it really easy to play because the
script just like laid out so well yeah
neil
how was it seeing all these actors bring
your characters to life
wonderful in all sorts of different ways
sometimes it will be wonderful because
it was exactly the thing that i've
always had in my head
you know tom
is morpheus once you see him on the
screen you go yeah that's the guy in the
comics that's what he
apparently sounds like and that's how he
moves because we haven't really seen him
move
sometimes it's
deeper or weirder
or just different
but it's always deeper or weirder or
different
in ways that make it more interesting
not less having viv
taking the character that that joe
orlando had created in the comics a long
time ago
and going is there any reason at all
that lucien can't look like that but
have pointy ears and going none that we
can think of great
and it suddenly allows a
level of honesty
that we didn't have with these
characters you know lucian
she can get mina or having
joanna constantine watching
what jenna brought
this
glorious heartbroken wounded bitter sass
to it
i was like oh that's exactly what i was
trying to get into you know into the
original comic with john only it's that
but more so yeah so we have some fan
questions for all of you alan noxie on
twitter ask what's it been to bring
something that's so beloved onto the
screen and what do you think viewers
should expect new and old fans of the
sandman from the show we wanted to give
longtime fans everything that they loved
about sandman reading sandman and then
more
more things that they
you know stuff that happens off panel
you know in the comic just a deeper dive
into these characters lives than their
feelings and their souls
a lot of our cast were new to the
sandman too so we couldn't just operate
within a fan bubble we really needed to
be able to tell the story for people
who've never read sandman before and it
was a pleasure to introduce people to
this world and these characters for the
first time so you really don't need to
have ever read the comics but if you see
the series and you enjoy it we hope
you'll run out and start reading because
there's a lot to enjoy i read them in
college and i remember having a huge
crush on dream and then watching the
episodes i forgot most of it but i'm
like oh yeah there's gonna be a lot of
questions
sorry tom
hey uh tom mel on twitter ask omg are we
gonna see dream's cool outfits question
mark question mark
omg are we going to see dreams cool
outfits yeah
omg yeah
omg
you'll see him without any
what he outfit wear in episode one
exactly right but sarah arthur our
costume designer was extraordinary and
um and very collaborative tom is very
involved yeah well what's what's
exciting about dream is is
you know within our story he
enters so many different worlds and
it was so important to
er
for him to carry the authority that he
has within these worlds who his dream in
hell like who is he in contemporary
london who is he in his own throne room
and it was such an enormous act of
imagination on her part and all of our
collaborators trying to answer those
questions which are not questions that
you get to do very often in a job like
this like normally it's like which are
the coolest jeans
um
and yeah it was magic so omg
well there's going to be a resurgence in
crushed velvet outfits i'll tell you
that
very cool jenna juliana aka
coleman's dimple on instagram asks
what can we expect from this new version
of joanna constantine
um
this new version of joanna constantine
um i guess um
if you would agree like an up an upgrade
she's been upgraded in her her clientele
clientele yeah yeah she's a bit posh
yeah yeah yeah she operates in a world
that's sort of at a higher level bro i
mean the queen and the royal family are
clients oh so you can't really get any
any higher than that is that a spoiler
sorry or lower
yes exactly
they'll cut that yeah
also did you know that your dimple had
an instagram handle no i did not
you guys should get together
um swirly on twitter ask vivian what is
it like being literally the best
character oh wow that's biased
the best i don't know like you know i
mean all the characters are the best
really so they're being very kind thank
you
you're a fan favorite um tom catladybean
on twitter asked is dream's helm an
actual prop and if so how did you make
it
well firstly i made it
it is a real prop um
and as neil said the most important
thing again it was an act of imagination
trying to create it there are so many
different images of it in
within the kind of the history of the
comics
but in overture um the source of it is
revealed which is a battle that um dream
has with a deposed god who has
imprisoned him in the dreaming um with
his love alianora and he he constructs a
helmet out of uh the god's skull and
spine so he never forgets the defeat
that he had when he was imprisoned and
what so what's important was that the
helm had that organic quality of a skull
and a spine um and wasn't this kind of
what it can sometimes be perceived as a
sort of space helmet
well we can actually inspect whether it
looks organic or not because we have the
real helm here helm girl
wow thank you
does that look like an organic spine of
a dead god
yeah i think it's very bony i'd say nine
out of ten
wonderful it's just going to sit here
watching us for the rest of this it's
going to be great um boyd
stephenrosariodz
on instagram asks is there a serial
killer convention coming soon
to a town near you yeah it's gonna be
great it's gonna be a full-on national
tour oh great
frightening
whenesu caravan city on twitter asks
what scene was the most difficult
it was
in i think episode 8 where i went into
hal's dream and i had to react to what i
was seeing on stage
because
we hadn't put the effects in yet
and he hadn't got a mask on yet it was
kind of hard to try and imagine what it
looked like and how terrifying it was
so my reaction was a bit smaller than it
probably would have if i saw that in
real life neil i am sad underscore
underscore ch on instagram
great handle how did neil gaiman manage
to make this story so grand and intimate
at the same time grand and intimate neil
uh i think it gets to be grand
mostly because
at the end of the day it's 3 000 pages
long so at that length you become an
epic whether that was where you started
out or not but also i think
one of the things that i wanted to try
and do when i was writing it was to
tackle
enormous
beings enormous ideas and
enormous time spans but the only way
that you can make anybody care about any
of that stuff
is by actually looking at
human beings and what happens to them
and
people's hearts and people's minds and
what happens to those
you know tom's
huge story as morpheus
would be so much less interesting
without a rose walker
without a joanna constantine
you need
what happens to them um
and their influence on him is actually
what drives season one
it's all about change and it's all about
beings who are bigger and greater than
gods and what they're going to become
this is a big reveal alan amanda pike on
twitter asks who is voicing merv
that is a big reveal and i'm going to
tell you we were thrilled to be able to
ask and get mark hamill
uh to be the voice of merv pumpkinhead
and he's fantastic in it
and he was such a pleasure to work with
neil and i had a day with him on zoom
and he could not have been
sweeter
can i try this can i try that what do
you need let me do it again i didn't
like that one i just i it just made me a
new kind of fan of his just i loved him
and his move is
hilarious
that's the other thing i think that
needs saying merv was always in the
comics
the
on the one hand a kind of comic relief
but on the other hand also the voice of
sanity the voice of just going
this is actually kind of nuts
he gets to be that person especially
when arguing with patton oswalt's
matthew
so much fun fans are going to go crazy
now it's time to answer the fan question
we've got more than any other when are
we finally going to see the sandman
debut on netflix alan i'm going to ask
you to the the honors as well all right
i have brought something special that i
think can show it
if you don't mind if i can if we can
just take over the stage all right let's
let's roll the tape as they say
i am the king of dreams
ruler of the nightmare
realm what are you doing here eddie he's
coming in he
you
morpheus
the anira mensah you know the same way
he's a fairy story eddie
he's no fairy story he's back good to
know
we're going to hand open your hands now
[Music]
forgive me messiah the palace
the realm
they are not as you left them
with you gone the realm began to decay
and crumble
[Music]
with looms and nightmares no longer seem
to recognize the monster
it will remind them
he's free
he's out of his cage
[Music]
wow
that looks so good did you have any
reactions that was amazing right
it seems so cliche but epic
yeah really epic the dreaming looks
amazing alan it must be so long
coming to this point how do you feel i i
cannot wait for fans and for new fans uh
people who've never heard of sandman
before to watch these incredible actors
tell this man's incredible story i could
not be more excited to share it with
everybody and have everybody finally see
it and fall in love the way i've fallen
in love so yeah neil what do you think
fans are going to think
i think fans
are going to be
incredibly excited because
this is sandman it's taken us
34 years to get sandman on screen i have
killed off so many bad sandmans
on the way
the bodies of so many dead sandman
movies i've been buried um
to do it right and to get to the point
where now
netflix would have the confidence in us
and assemble
amazing actors amazing people to do it
and it's sandman and that's what i think
people are going to be responding to the
thing they love
it's on the screen
well as a fan
he definitely did it right i could keep
talking to all of you all day but
unfortunately that is all the time we
have for today's special geek week panel
for the sandman thank you so much for
taking the time to chat with us at geek
week this year
and fortunately we don't have to wait
much longer until the salmon hits
netflix we finally finally finally can
announce that it will be coming to a
stream device near you on august 5th so
we will be back with this fabulous crew
for a special episode of the sandman
unlocked where we will go into all
full spoilery details for now i'm
felicia day and be sure to keep watching
geeked week all week long for more
exciting reveals
bye
hey everyone it's elliot just wanted to
say thank you for all your continued
love and support we have the absolute
best fans in the world and what we
wanted to do is answer some of your most
burning questions
hey what's up everyone it's david it's
tom
hi everybody it's emmy hello it's me
robert hey everybody it's aidan hey
everyone it's ritu
shooting the final scene of season two
was incredibly fun it was really funny
justin min had to wear a certain
specific kind of hair and the whole time
i just kept calling him baby diego it
was really nice to to be able to
actually look at justin h man in the
face for the first time in two years we
didn't know all the details so the
surprise about ben at the end was a
surprise for us uh confusing because
none of the actors that had been cast as
sparrows this year were actually cast
yet so there was just silhouettes
don't start now i do leave up 433 by
john cage it's a banger creep by
radiohead
smash mouth world star all star
i think it's my way by frank sinatra
stan eminem
[Music]
fun
fun
exhilarating
chaotic debauchery and or shenanigans
chaotic no no no hilarious
no no no
destruction
[Music]
s club seven there are seven psychopaths
in the movie seven psychopaths sins seas
chocolates dwarves seven dwarfs
wonders of the world umbrellas
uh golden brown it's either don't stop
me now
or
here comes the end the
sister sisters
i did it my
way everybody backstreet boys
back streets back all right uh
backstreet boys i know that's probably
everyone's answers
[Music]
morning bird oh
she is a morning bird okay night owl
morning morning night out both morning
bird catches the worm
[Music]
me
or
david
or aiden justin aiden i certainly do it
a lot so it could be me
me time with elliott 100 if the three of
us are in a scene that's a wrap we never
give it them
[Music]
no one
me
yeah no one aiden's pretty good at not
breaking aiden is pretty i have to say
clearly the most professional of us all
what else is new hey thanks so much
umbrella fans thank you so much umbrella
fans thanks so much umbrella fans we
love you we love you and we can't wait
to show season three we truly can't wait
to share season three with you this
isn't your home
what are you talking about this is the
umbrella academy
this is the sparrow academy
[ __ ]
[Music]
when we jumped here we created a time
paradox our little paradox brought forth
the freaking cougar blitz what the hell
is the cougar blitz essentially we're
screwed
[Music]
everybody else could see ben right yeah
and he's a complete [ __ ]
they're all [ __ ]
[ __ ] who can fight
next person to say [ __ ] is getting a
punch to the throat [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
we caused a paradox and that paradox is
swallowing things how long do we have
four maybe five days before the rest of
existence is blitzed not to mention
we've been replaced by a bunch of blobs
and cubes and birds and [ __ ]
your team is good but i don't think
you're better than me
i entered the world twice and you you're
just meeting spandex
dad didn't adopt us as babies but those
babies still existed here so if you ever
see your other selves kill them sleep
with them avoid them the hell is wrong
with you oh come on as if you wouldn't
climb luther mountain
[Music]
if i kill you do we get our vent back
what the hell did you just say
what are you their mascot
more like their ringer
[Music]
i'm looking for you
spoiler alert
[Music]
the real housewives of the umbrella
academy reunion here we go this isn't
your home
what are you talking about this is the
umbrella academy
this is the sparrow academy
[ __ ] hello hello geek tweak i am felicia
day and i am so excited to be here for
this very special geeked week panel for
the umbrella academy yes finally all
those purple umbrellas in the chat have
paid off we are going to treat you to
some exclusive first looks at season
three and just a little bit but
wanna know what's even more of a treat i
have gathered up as many of the fabulous
cast behind the umbrella academy as i
could to share those first looks with
you so without further ado let's welcome
our panel
tom hopper who plays the number one in
our hearts and for the umbrella academy
luther
david castaneda who plays master of
knives and the burelli's number two
diego
amy raver lantman who i heard a rumor
plays the fabulous number three alison
ayden gallagher who plays the well
overdue for not having apocalypse crisis
is to deal with number five
hey
justin h moon who plays ben now uh
number two of the sparrow academy we
have to talk about that
and genesis rodriguez as the newest
member of our cast the number five of
the sparrow academy salon thank you
everybody for being here thank you also
to everyone who responded to at the
umbrella academy and at netflix geeks
with your fan questions for this panel
we got so many of them we will do our
best to answer as many as we can
throughout the show
so season two ended up with quite a
cliffhanger can you guys talk about uh
where things pick up for season three
for each of your characters tom do you
want to start
um
well i guess we start
with seeing the sparrow academy right
and then dealing with uh
the fact that this is not our timeline
anymore right
so i think for luther
i think the pressure's off for him now
initially right i think the until any
problems start occurring he thinks oh
great well we can just kind of get on
with our lives here then because we
don't have any pressure we can just
crack on so uh yeah that's certainly
where it starts for for luther and until
as i say problems start happening yeah
maybe pretty much immediately yeah emmy
where is allison in this moment when you
start off season three uh i think
everyone's a little jumbled by the fact
that we've come home to find out that
our home is not our home and there's
strangers
on the balcony
david seems pretty
your character seems pretty aggro when
you see everybody are you ready ready to
start fighting yeah
yeah so sort of an identity crisis
um but i think allison's priority the
reason that she she agreed to go with
the rest of the family and leave the 60s
was to get home to her daughter so
that's her first
priority and her only priority to be
honest yeah as any mother would yeah any
good mother yeah i guess not judge
anybody's mother sorry mom
how is phi feeling when you see this i
mean you probably have seen enough
disaster to you know fill the whole
garbage can what are you thinking right
now when you see this other team i think
he's flustered i mean he's seen his fair
share of
crazy timeline and whatnot so he keeps
an eye on the briefcase but uh
yeah it's in the back of his mind
whether or not to use that because who
knows this might be fine it might just
be that uh we're out of a home in which
case just
i don't know find a kind of realtor or
something exactly literally
yeah
[Laughter]
now justin you are on the other side of
the the world you're facing off against
your old brellis how does that feel
trader oh wow
starting
off spicy
we
are set up where we're having a typical
day at the sparrow academy our beautiful
home and then suddenly out of nowhere
these strangers appear and
they're looking at ben in this odd way
so it's i think he's startled and also
suspicious of who these people are and
why they're here yeah alternate universe
alternate academy let's talk about the
sparrows genesis what do we need to know
about the sparrow academy in general
the sparrow academy is a completely
different family
equally as dysfunctional
but they really are crime fighters
they're organized they have trained
their entire lives
and they've dedicated their
lives to
stopping crime and they're kind of um
they're kind of a big deal
they're very popular
they're very popular and that's a
billboard it's a billboard they're a
brand yeah they're a brand so they've
succeeded where the burellis maybe
haven't as far as marketing wow maybe
billboards should say we're kind of a
big deal
well we have our first sneak peek for
geek week we brought everyone an
exclusive clip so i hope you're excited
about that let's take a look
big one is strong but slow
possibly stupid
some sort of
simian hybrid who took the little jumpy
guy me just give him a spanking and send
him to school hello
this skinny one is their weak link
unless hiding behind couches shouting
where's my daddy it's a superpower
they disrespected us marcus we need to
be out there finding these freaks and
taking them out oh you mean like this
i mean we haven't faced decent enemies
for years
this
could be good for us
good for business but only
if we're smart with our next move
yes
okay
you clearly had a trainer too you you're
you're ripped oh
uh yes they uh they had all of us on
quite intense training regimens before
we started the show
and so it was sort of nice to get into
the character in in a physical way in a
way that we haven't been able or i
haven't been able to do previously for
the show so well i'm sure the fans will
appreciate it your dedication
david will and that's all that matters
i always do
[Laughter]
on twitter asks for justin what was it
like to work with a new group of people
with new powers yeah justin
it was wonderful i mean i think we had
chemistry right away uh we uh it almost
felt like working on a new show i was
playing sort of a new character with a
new cast and
we got to zoom a number of times before
starting filming
and i just felt like it really worked
immediately and uh it's so lovely it's
so lovely of course you know i love
these guys as well but did you miss it
at all
emmy's face seems a little skeptical
the thing is we so rarely got to
actually do scenes with him yeah you
know
he was just around they actually got to
look him in the eyes yeah we weren't
allowed to for two seasons because he
was dead yeah okay so flip side but yeah
absolutely can anybody tell me what's up
with the cube christopher the cube is he
like a good roommate what do you think
he's very opinionated yeah i do have to
say
um follow-up to all of you actually who
would win in a fight you or your
number opposite so like tom luther
versus marcus who would win
tight
really
i'm good just for my own ego tight time
okay uh
but
he's probably a touch faster than
sluggish luther
maybe yeah all right what about diego
versus ben i think i think ben would win
you know uh but ben would cry
he'd win but he'd cry i was gonna say
you would cry no but you would win
though i would cry i would win and you
would cry because hold on he's emotional
because the knife will cut your
tentacles dude and it would hurt you
okay and make you cry yeah that would
suck i could see that but i think i
would ben would kill diego before the
knives could even come out i wouldn't
die wow it's like a tennis match over
here
why wouldn't you die
because diego's lovable dude you can't
kill diego okay
so you're saying that ben's not so
lovable no i'm he's terrible
he's terrible he's a [ __ ]
are we talking about life
no ben
of course no justin's a little
that's marshmallow compliment
um emmy allison versus faye who would
win oh man
i think allison absolutely oh
okay
she's the most powerful of them all yeah
she just had to say three words yeah
yeah i was trying i was i was thinking
it from the physical aspect just like
actual hand-to-hand combat
oh punching yeah yeah i mean you know
but but also yeah i do if you actually
usually power is crazy yeah that's
really incredible so yeah i'd probably
say okay you take her out um aidan
versus genesis we have you can do it
right now
[Laughter]
i think five would defuse the conflict
rather than fight like he
you know he
talk it out well he'll talk it out see
if you guys are actually a threat or
just like you're in our house we weren't
expecting guests we need to prepare
before
over a drink yeah so you would negotiate
your way out of any conflict i would i
think five would
make sure he understood the scenario
before he starts killing people okay oh
wow you've never done that before
you just kill people
am i just saying the same show i don't i
check like the guest list who's in the
board room before i head in with the axe
okay
yeah just forget the whole assassin's
creed thing
[Laughter]
but if i wasn't quick she would totally
win
yeah he's just got that blink thing so
yes he's got to be quick yeah yeah
gravity gal gravity
the berelli's evolved so much each
season and the sparrows certainly are a
new challenge what different sides of
your characters are you most excited to
explore in season three tom let's start
with you
i think
luther lets go of a lot of his
hang-ups
so he's more fun to play this year he's
he's uh i think i feel like this year he
gets to play out his missed teenage
years a little bit mm-hmm i'll say that
yeah
i'm sorry whenever i look at you you
look so skinny
i mean it's almost startling like you
know like one of those 80s
this guy could use a leg day that's all
i could say um david what about you
what about your character in season
three uh i think they're bigger than
mine
sorry no i i think it's more about um
you know he's always wanted to say
well prove himself
and now he's not at home anymore and
there's another academy so he's a bit
lost he doesn't know what to do so he
wants to just focus his whole attention
into like trying to get the sparrow
academy
out
obviously you know surprises happen that
lead him in a different direction that
you know kind of helps him find purpose
you know so he's kind of purposeless at
the beginning he doesn't know what to do
with himself and that's kind of the
journey that he goes into i think until
you know the end of season three yeah
yeah emmy where does allison go i mean
you've been a lot of places yeah first
couple seasons yeah where are you going
from here
um
i think
alison's got some trauma that she needs
to
to kind of deal with and and move
through and work through and so i think
that's a lot of
a lot of her season is kind of
coming back from the 60s and
dealing with
what she experienced and witnessed and
lived through and survived to be
completely honest um
and that affects her emotionally
mentally
physically
um so i think that's that's a lot of her
season is kind of dealing with the
aftermath of coming back from the being
a black woman in the 60s in dallas texas
yeah and just a lot of trauma yeah a lot
aidan where's five going from here i
mean you've had to manage so much so
much time travel what are you just
hoping for
he goes straight to the horse races and
he kicks back
yeah he's he's looking for a break you
know he's been going at it non-stop for
like two weeks now
[Laughter]
wow
when you summarize the show like that
it's a little scary
captain christine asked for justin how
did you choose what traits to bring for
this version of ben is this been a
different bend than we've seen before
absolutely i think
a lot of what steve flackman and i steve
blackman our schwinner and i talked
about was sort of playing around with
this whole idea of nature versus nurture
and how much of
sort of the essence of ben we wanted to
keep and how
much he would change because of this
sort of different environment that he
grew up in and
i think ben as his essence is a very
impressionable person so the nurture
part of it plays a much much larger role
in his life than for potentially other
characters so to grow up in an
environment that felt more militant and
you know
training to be a crime fighter in all of
these ways it really toughened him up in
a
in a way that he wasn't in the previous
timeline he's sort of has a large chip
on his shoulder so that's something that
we wanted to bring into play as well
yeah your dad doesn't feel very
nurturing this season absolutely
ever
jenna says how do the sparrows serve as
foils for the brellis i mean they're
matched power wise but are they matched
personality wise too do you have
anything in common with
five
um personality wise i wouldn't i
wouldn't say
uh were two different fives i believe
but i think that there are some matches
within both of the families for sure
um right
yeah right you think luther has anything
in common with marcus and i think marcus
is the leader that luther always wanted
to be
wow deep yeah allison anything with faye
do you have any
match up there um their love of birds
[Laughter]
just didn't make the cut um they're both
sassy as hell yeah i think they're both
very very strong very very opinionated
and
and um
and sassy but i also think that they are
they do have this ability to like to
put themselves put their family first
and kind of do what needs to be done
for the greater good of the family yeah
i think both both threes are kind of
good at being kind of like the pillar of
that yeah absolutely kind of the center
and then diego and that you guys are
just resentful you have you seem to have
that in common resentment
i think you're everything that
uh-oh ben wants
you're everything that
exactly what tom said about luther right
what
do you ben is everything diego wants to
be i feel like we're they're both in the
same place they are they are i think so
they both have a chip on their they both
have a number two chip yeah i think the
i think the difference is that like
uh
diego is uh not he's he's not afraid of
making a fool out of himself
you know he really will go there you
know so he's but yeah i think very much
both have a like a
uh imposter syndrome and wanting to
prove themselves yeah yeah
fifth umbrella on twitter asked if your
character could have any of the
sparrow's powers or the sparrows vice
versa which would they pick i mean you
want to start um my answer has always
been the same for three seasons of the
show i think uh
i would keep allison's power
it's pretty powerful yeah aiden i've
been saying for years that gravity
manipulation would be a really cool
power to have
uh and then it appeared on the show and
i was really happy to see that yeah yeah
very cool justin
i've grown attached to the tentacles so
literally
literally
um
my octopus teacher is also a great
documentary on netflix yes also on
netflix
check it out on netflix
but inspiring david what about you wait
what's marcus's power he's the same as
luther yeah
superstructures
yeah okay so it's so it's kind of
identical then yeah yeah it's kind of
the same although luther has no real
obvious power in the show just strong
argue
he can eat a lot yeah i lifted up a
tractor in season two yeah he wrote the
wikipedia and still then with a slight
struggle but you're still strong i mean
you lifted me up in season one i lifted
you up remember yeah when we came in it
was like oh yeah so i'm not like crazy
crazy strong yeah which i thought was
funny because the knives even punctured
your arm remember yeah exactly yeah yeah
i was like
genesis
uh i really like my power a lot uh i
really love lila's power because she
gets all the powers so i'm going to go
with lyla that feels like a cheat yeah i
never say that because i feel like
she also gets none of them if we're not
in the area
well
played but then doesn't need them right
until she's in our area
true right huh until she's amongst us
she doesn't need the power
right so when she's off on her own she's
like i don't need it right right now
when she's fighting us that's when she
needs it and she can use any of them
okay that's like wishing for more wishes
but okay and you already answered would
you want to be more like marcus just
like maybe more you can flip at least
no
no
i'm still i've experienced two seasons
of like a mediocre version of marcus
okay so like just upgrading to marcus it
sounds like it doesn't serve me whereas
i think kazzy's power is quite good
being able to yeah that's quite fun as
well wait has that been revealed yeah
we'll just do it okay can well here's
the question can jamie
see the other person's dream yeah mm-hmm
something like that
that's fun which is cool
well we couldn't let a season of the
umbrella academy go without
you guessed it twitter emojis you will
get a special surprise depending on
whether or not you're using light or
dark mode so go take a look
with the sparrows we also get a fan
favorite setting introduced in season
three hotel obsidian in season one we
had the umbrella mansion in season two
we were in the 60s what does this new
setting of hotel obsidian add to the
story david
well i mean the just the production of
it is just insane we got to walk in the
first time it was like you were
transported into a different world it
was beautiful how they were able to put
it and we shot throughout that whole
thing so it it pretty much became the
backbone to the whole story yeah genesis
did the sparrow spend a lot of time at
this hotel or is this i think something
you knew you find out in the season yes
there's quite a bit
quite a bit in that new space and it i
mean really what they were able to do it
set wise it was actually incredible
and with some like um interesting
materials too wasn't there like a paper
cup holder oh yeah that was disguised as
wall and they were very
well
i think it looks a little tired
the obsidian it looks like one of those
older vegas hotels
you know
stained carpet
lots of not like this smoke stained
ceilings yeah
[Laughter]
well that perfectly sets us up for
another exclusive clip reveal from
season three premiere let us take a look
[Music]
oh okay
honestly
[Music]
there were two entrances by the way
oh
hotel obsidian i missed you [ __ ] old
dame
absorb her absorb her into your bosom
you know cause back in her heyday she
played host to world leaders roosevelt
gandhi stalin gorbachev castro king olaf
of norway one of the kim jongs tito
dalai lama elvis and not one
but two kardashians a legend
wouldn't that where are you going i
gotta make a call nowadays she's just a
flop house party house for those of us
not looking to be judged by society's
rules and norms
you need a place to hide exactly it's
perfect and the best part of it is she's
gonna look after us no questions asked
i may have questions yeah me too
this place is
weird
seems like klaus if he recommends a
hotel it's probably not going to be a
good experience huh
it's tricky though in that moment we
needed some place that they couldn't
find us so actually klaus was the
perfect person
to recommend a hotel because we needed
to go to the most unlikely space yeah
but you're right the the production
design is pretty astonishing yeah
incredible yeah it's insane well we have
time for a few more questions from fans
uh d 2007
underscore underscore on instagram for
tom who is your favorite new character
of season three
oh
actually
i would probably say
the new ben
yeah
because
yeah it's pretty great it's great
because it's such a it's so different to
the ben that we knew as the umbrella so
i think it's just such a great shift in
the show and it brings a whole new
dynamic to
to also to your your as an actor as well
i think it was brilliant you know
working with with justin this year was
it was so much fun
and uh yeah so i can't wait for people
to see it it's gonna it's gonna be good
sloane hargreaves on twitter asked david
how many knives do you think diego owns
17.
there it is
is that how many you have on you yeah is
that and that's all okay but what do you
have in storage like that's all i have
why do you have no storage
constantly looking at knives i'm very
much making sure that i don't lose any
of them you got a fan convention
so there's like a scene right after
whatever fight scene where you're just
picking up knives yeah well it's between
the scenes where i'm picking up the
knives you know it's like the boring
stuff no one will see me pick up knives
that would throw them a fun blooper reel
sorry to just go off i'm just very
curious
uh
sorry no keep going i love knives
wow
especially sharpies
you know on twitter for emmy ask who do
you think is the most powerful amongst
the siblings
oh
sparrows and umbrellas yeah oh yeah yeah
open it up you can know so many people
yeah
um
i mean i
i think i would probably
say lila right because she's the
chameleon and she can take on
any power so you're always going to be
matched by your equal if you go up
against her which is
pretty dangerous pretty great yeah
chickadee on instagram asks aiden do you
think you would get along with your
character this season
ah
i'm way too silly for five he would have
none of me
as we just saw with the knife
conversation i would love to see that
i would love to he'd wait for the coffee
to arrive he'd enjoy it and then calmly
walk out
if i didn't annoy him too much first and
then he would yeah i don't know
i don't think he'd like me
he'd be curious he's like who's this guy
who looks exactly like me are we twins
who this other one didn't have powers
and it's just
i don't know
captain caitlin on twitter for justin
how does the umbrella academy respond to
this very different ben
they're very conflicted because
obviously he looks like
they're ben but he
acts very differently and
there are many looks
shared throughout the show uh especially
in the first few episodes where
they sort of see
their ben but it's not who they think he
is anymore yeah that must be hard as an
actor when you guys have worked for so
many years together being one person for
you to remove yourself from them and be
a completely different person absolutely
but on the flip side as as was pointed
out it was nice to finally look my
fellow actors in the eyes for the first
time yeah it was it was it was likewise
yeah yeah
liam on twitter for genesis asks what is
your favorite episode you filmed for
next season oh
no spoilers i can't i can't i don't know
you can get a number you can give a
number
uh
one
um
before i let you go we're going to play
a little game i like to call spoilers
without context okay so the rules are
very simple i want you to share
something cryptic uh there's a massive
spoiler that only will make sense once
the fans have seen the whole season so
it could be a sound it could be a
gesture a facial expression a word
anything that gives you a clue in
context only if you've seen the season
tom i'm sorry
wow
yikes
we i have something you have something
good yeah yes please
roll up the carpet i'll just leave it at
that
um i'll say i'll say
i'm going to need my bow tie
emmy
bacon
bacon
yes
bacon bacon bacon yeah it's a good one
food so now i'm being inspired by food
shrimp cocktail and lamb chops
definitely nice lamb
okay
okay aiden i'm just gonna say the word
breaks look at the past stuff that's
already come out and if you look for the
word breaks
uh you'll you'll find a mild spoiler
that won't make sense yet
okay thank you so much everybody got it
[Music]
if i kill you do we get our vent back
what the hell did you just say
what are you their mascots
more like their ringers
[Music]
consider me sufficiently teased i could
keep talking to you all day but
unfortunately that's all the time we
have for today's special geeked week
panel for the umbrella academy thank you
so much for taking the time to chat with
us for geeked week this year
fortunately we don't have to wait much
longer until the umbrella academy hits
netflix on june 22nd it's near my
birthday so thank you very much
you're welcome
and we will be back with this fabulous
crew for a special episode of our
netflix geeked after show the umbrella
academy unlocked where we will go into
full spoilery details after the season
premieres all right see you soon thanks
bye
bye
getting ready for a new season of the
umbrella academy you'll find news videos
interviews and more onto doom the
official netflix site to help find and
fuel your fandom from rehashing the
finale to re-watching the latest trailer
find more information than the
commission on netflix.com
this isn't your home
what are you talking about this is the
umbrella academy this is the sparrow
academy
[ __ ]
[Music]
when we jumped here we created a time
paradox our little paradox brought forth
the freaking kugelblitz what the hell is
the cougar blitz essentially we're
screwed
[Music]
everybody else could see ben right yeah
and he's a complete [ __ ]
they're all [ __ ]
[ __ ] who can fight
next person to say [ __ ] is getting a
punch to the throat [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
we caused a paradox and that paradox is
swallowing things
how long do we have four maybe five days
before the rest of existence is blitzed
not to mention we've been replaced by a
bunch of blobs and cubes and birds and
[ __ ]
your team is good but i don't think
you're better than me i ended the world
twice and you you're just meeting
spandex
dad didn't adopt us as babies but those
babies still existed here so if you ever
see your other self kill them sleep with
them avoid them the hell is wrong with
you oh come on as if you wouldn't climb
luther mountain
[Music]
if i kill you do we get our vent back
what the hell did you just say
what are you their mascots
more like their ringer
[Music]
i'm looking for you
spoiler alert
mama let's go we're late do i have to
your grandson's birthday only happens
once a year so does geek tweet
[Music]
stranger things panel starts in 15.
[Music]
sorry it's geeked week
netflix geek week 2022 june 6-10
[Music]
i'm from a lineage thousands of years
old of the best monster hunters to ever
walk the earth
[Music]
even on good days i feel like i still
don't fit in
like everyone else has it all figured
out
oh yeah
that i haven't told anyone of course
you said you are a legacy vampire made
vampires with love see their reflection
in a mirror
we're hunters
more importantly you're my daughter
which is why we've decided you're ready
for your first kill used to killing
monsters
your body is changing my body but very
soon you are going to have to make your
first kill
hi it's juliet right yeah you're calling
well cow's good
who are you kalai
where'd you come from
addicted to lavanya
how does it feel
do nothing like the monsters i grew up
hating i just want to live my life
you can't be together it won't work i've
forbidden you from seeing her
we're not supposed to be i know my
feelings for you are real julia and
every legacy in savannah dies tonight
run now
keep your things in your mouth we won't
have a problem we will always have a
problem
i had to choose between you and my
family
i choose my family
what about us
faced everyone monster and human who
tried to come between us
we got this
i'll kill for you
pogo
get off the couch
want to go for a walk
hey buddy come on fetch
pogo
what's this
oh pogo we all want to watch geek week
netflix geek week 2022 june 6 to 10.
[Music]
greetings bloodthirsty babes i am
princess week's part-time vampire witch
hybrid and full-time host writer gamer
and lover of all things geek
welcome to most presents vampire pride
most is netflix's destination for all
things lgbtq storytelling on instagram
and twitter
now this friday june 10th marks the
release of the highly anticipated teen
vampire drama series first kill
first kill centers on teen vampire
juliet who has yet to bite her first
victim as she falls for her classmate
calliope little does little juliet know
calliope and her family are vampire
hunters
so will their love for each other be
strong enough
or will their family's expectations
prevail to be honest you had me at
leading lesbian vampires
i can feel my teeth sharpening already
take a bite out of this exclusive clip
from the netflix show first kill
hi
hi
[Music]
wow okay
not wasting any time huh sorry i'm
socially awkward
um
and i've wanted to do that for a while
now
and would like to do it again
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
be
[Music]
i'm a slave for you baby miss britney
spears i'm a club taurus ringing all for
cheers and i'm sexy like christina when
i dip below
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
i'm imani lewis and i'm sarah catherine
hook and we're going to take you through
a scene from first kill shot by shot
this is unseen
[Music]
so we are about to watch the scene in
noah harrington's party where
juliet and cal lock eyes for the first
time that night
[Music]
oh there she is
julia and calliope are really just
classmates by this point maybe it's a
calliope
but they both have their own you know
hidden agendas i would say juliet is
definitely there to get her flirt on
with calliope yeah that's all she's
expecting what happens next may not have
been on juliet's agenda
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me too
i i know i feel bad because i actually
don't know if i've actually played the
bottle oh yeah
so that was our that was our first time
like yeah
you got to see it
[Music]
juliet is more on the reserved like shy
sensitive side she might not be as
experienced as
the rest of the crowd
um
but when clivy comes to town she's just
head over heels
hi
hi she kind of establishes that juliet
was the first person to really even say
anything to her in the school and to
even acknowledge her presence although
she knows juliet's truth she doesn't
appear
to be like any of the things she was
taught to fear or train to kill
[Music]
wow okay
not wasting any time huh sorry i'm
socially awkward
um
and have wanted to do that for a while
now we know
i would like to do it again
um
okay
i don't think calliope thinks juliette
has her figured out no definitely not i
don't think juliette just thinks
you're cool yeah hot i think collab he's
using that to her advantage to like
that's like bait you know
she's like oh my gosh she likes me no
she just wants to stay cute
i could also imagine her being like
having this fear of rejection thing like
just having lots of different thoughts
swimming through her head like what's
gonna happen right but we all know what
juliette wants
it's plain and simple
[Music]
[Music]
this is my favorite part
that part right there that's my favorite
we were like huddled to the side having
to hold one another while they're
setting up camera and we were just like
it's useless to walk away right and we
are holding each other and just messing
around and i felt her stake all of a
sudden i was like
shirts and shane we just lost it i mean
on the floor crying
and like everyone's like trying to like
operate the camera and everything we're
delirious at this point too we've just
been making out all day all day
[Music]
i'm so glad we can share this moment
with you me too i'm watching us make out
[Music]
and the cherries
yeah i was waiting for this classic
cherries we knocked over the cherries
one time
one take wonders
i'm trying to move my back off the wall
almost like a dance to get my hand in my
the back of my shorts to get the steak
and i was like it's so funny like
i feel like that's how like
seahorses do it like they like just ride
this way and we just kept making jokes
about sea horsing around yeah very
seriously you know making out pushing up
against the wall and it's like dead
silent everyone's super focused great
i'll put your hand there all right now
put your hand here uh okay i'll do the
seahorse and it was just so we lost it
completely lost immediately it was done
[Laughter]
yeah that's crazy those moments for
vampires are so iconic and i i i don't
know yeah it was it was amazing like how
could it not be it was so fun and i just
wanted to keep doing it keep going going
um and i honestly i feel so happy with
the way that it turned out i think it
just i mean the entire scene like it's
just so beautifully shot and i yeah i
really think people will love it thank
you for watching this biting shot by
shot breakdown check out first kill this
friday
i want to shamelessly plug a new digital
series i'm hosting for most yes me and
netflix is still watching netflix
youtube channel titled dismantled in the
first episode i'll be breaking down the
barrier gage trope and it's historically
harmful
and trash representations of lgbtq
characters in horror and other genres
better yet
here's a taste
we are here to talk about on-screen
death but
in a fun educational queer way while
lgbtq coded characters have always
existed i mean duh we're fabulous we've
been here since the earth began in the
late 19th and 20th centuries we saw film
and literature feature same gender
romantic couples but one of the lovers
was killed died or somehow miserable by
the end of the film this is what makes
netflix's lesbian vampire love story
first kill feels so epic and radical
not only are both cal and juliet openly
and loudly queer but their conflict is
that one is a vampire and the other a
vampire hunter lgbtq horror fans want to
be included not just as victims but as
final boys girls non-binary hotties
hollywood has been a long time burying
the gays but we have risen
and we are hungry
angelina jolie once said
when other little girls wanted to be
ballet dancers
i kind of wanted to be a vampire
and thanks to sarah catherine and
amani's portrayals of juliet and
calliope and fur's kill i feel that
quote now more than ever
like any show or film based on a written
body of work fans are sure to spot the
parallels and differences from what they
read to what they see in its adaptation
we had our star vamps sarah catherine
and imani as well as author writer and
executive producer victoria schwab
read a passage from the original short
story to start that research for you
enjoy story time with this trio reading
what i like to call fang fiction
the door swings shut plunging them both
into the dark dark it's a relative thing
light spills beneath the bottom of the
door
and juliet's eye steal the sliver
use it to paint the details of the
crowded closet the coats taking up 90 of
the space a pile of boxes around their
feet the hangers knocking into the back
of her head and calliope not some stolen
sideways glance but right here the slope
of her neck and the curve of her mouth
and those steady brown eyes somehow warm
and sharp
hi
she says
her voice low and short
hi whispers juliet
trying to sound like her sister with her
airy confidence but it comes out all
wrong less like a breath and more like a
whistle a squeak
clip he laughs less at her than at this
the crowded closet the closeness of
their bodies and for once the other girl
seems nervous too
tense like she's holding her breath
but she doesn't pull away
jules hesitates thinks she should either
be closer together or further apart
ben never said what they were supposed
to do
60 seconds isn't much time
60 seconds is forever calliope smells
good
of course she does but it's her lotion
or her chapstick
it's her
jules is flare and narrow until all she
can smell is the other girl's skin and
her sweat and her blood
blood
and something else
something she can't place
something that sends warning bells
ringing duly through her head
but then collide be kisses her
her mouth is so soft
her lips parting between hers and there
are no fireworks
the world doesn't stop
she doesn't taste like magic or sunshine
she tastes like the grapefruit soda she
was drinking
like fresh air and sugar and something
simple and human
well if that left you craving more
vampires and hunters now would probably
be the time for you to check out first
kill and lucky for you it's streaming
this friday only on netflix
i wish i could talk all things vampire
with you forever but
the sun is rising and i must return to
my casket
be sure to catch first kill this friday
june 10th on netflix and don't miss me
co-host a special live recording of the
geeked podcast this friday right here on
the geeked week live stream
see you then
i'm from a lineage thousands of years
old of the best monster hunters to ever
walk the earth
[Music]
even on good days i feel like i still
don't fit in
like everyone else has it all figured
out
oh yeah
that i haven't told anyone of course
you are a legacy vampire made vampires
with love see their reflection in a
mirror
we're hunters
more importantly you're my daughter
which is why we've decided you're ready
for your first kill used to killing
monsters
your body is changing my body but very
soon you are going to have to make your
first kill
hi it's juliette right yeah you're
kallivi oh cow's good
who are you kalai where'd you come from
addicted to lavender how does it feel
you're nothing like the monsters i grew
up hating i just want to live my life
you can't be together it won't work i've
forbidden you from seeing her we're not
supposed to be i know my feelings for
you are real julia and every legacy in
savannah dies tonight
run now
keep your things in your mouth we won't
have a problem we will always have a
problem
i had to choose between you and my
family
i choose my family
what about us
faced everyone monster and human who
tried to come between us we got this
i'll kill for you
want to stay in the know about your
favorite netflix shows and films you'll
find news videos interviews and more on
taboom the official netflix site to help
find and fuel your fandom stranger
things the gray man the umbrella academy
and more make week week last all year on
netflix week last all year on
netflix.com